I love your gown who made it um my dear
friend Jackson wiederhoff made it and
then Judith Lieber made this little pink
shoe pet tell me a little secret about
your outfit this evening have you had
any snap Foods or any challenges getting
so that could be a minor tear somewhere
but I'm not going to tell you where it's
hard to sit in traffic in a corset isn't
it it is it's really a challenge
tonight when you've got a bevy of
celebrities in front of you are you
inclined to get some material for your
impressions well a lot of the people I
do might be coming tonight and we've
never had a face to face so do you bring
out do you best out there no I don't I
don't want to like humiliate myself but
then I kind of also do how are you
prepping for SNL with Pete Davidson
making his way back to this day I'll
probably find him while he's eating a
bread roll and be like what do you want
to do I miss pitch just they're all
pitching ideas right now and I'm in a
ball gown but you know that's what the
bread rolls are for a salad course or
I'll find them in a bathroom or
something thank you
[Music]
foreign